[Music]
welcome back everybody we've got mr don
in the seat today
even though we're talking about a random
article but he's here sorry hot dog hi
don and i really like your hat thank you
throw that out there as well thank you
so much normalized men complimenting men
normalize it hey and hey nick you got
pretty eyes i think they're just normal
brown eyes but jealous
[Laughter]
ukraine's zilinski signs virtual assets
bill into law legalizing crypto in
ukraine
and they have just in case nobody's been
paying attention received over 100
million dollars in donations in crypto
to assist their war efforts last time i
i thought it was less than 20 so that
was fast over 100 million didn't um
coinbase and some other platforms
blocked it in russia right
that's what i read i read that i think
because of sanctions yeah yeah towards
russia yeah centralized exchanges but in
ukraine it's cool wait uh what do they
mean by legalizing crypto you mean prior
to the war things like those apps or
centralized exchanges um
can be in conversation different from
like uh their crypto regulations in
terms of acceptance in the nation does
that make sense nope
one more time in the same way that uh uh
something like a coin base can like stop
working for russian citizens because of
sanctions they can also technically stop
working in general because of like the
macroeconomic situation oh yeah but it
doesn't mean that like crypto is uh
can't work in their country does that
make sense they could still use the now
you have to say yes i'm not stupid
you're stupid yeah you're dumb dude we
get it
it goes against like a centralized
system so they can still use it but they
can't yeah use it for specific i think
the birth and the idealism of bitcoin
specifically yes but there's a lot of
crypto that is they're centralized for
centralization as well so but yes the
the ethos of bitcoin is to be
decentralized so it can't be stopped you
know what i mean because i think one of
the the popular memes that's going
around right now is uh the ethos is to
be centralized no no no decentralized
uh but one of these one of these things
where putin's talked about how like this
war has brought forth the idea that
things like foreign exchanges right it
can just be like seized by us diplomats
or whatever at any moment this is not a
foreign exchange is it it's a u.s
controlled still yeah yeah so there's a
really kind of a hot moment for the
world to kind of be paying attention to
life and it's so good for crypto oh i
was like a moan
if you make enough money it might be
moaning you
loans know russia it's very bullish why
is it bullish um okay before i answer
that i want to know why like what does
it mean to be like crypto is legal in
ukraine because they were already taking
donations before he announced it was
legal so does that mean at that time it
was illegal or there was a weird status
it was probably a weird status this says
that uh ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky legalized crypto in the country
signing into law a bill on virtual
assets amid a frenzy of digital asset
donations to support the country's
defense against the russian invasion the
law determines the legal status
classification ownership and regulators
of virtual assets as well as setting
registration requirements for crypto
services providers providers the
ministry of digital transformation said
um and the market will be regulated by
ukraine's national commission on
securities and the stock market
exchanges will be able to operate
legally and banks will open accounts for
them
and that's the state body is tasked with
shaping and pursuing a policy in the
field of virtual assets determining the
order of circulation of virtual assets
issuing permits to virtual asset service
providers and carrying out supervision
and financial monitoring in this area so
so in layman's they're just recognizing
that you can use it just as good as
legal tender so go ahead and i have you
have my blessing and the nation's
blessing to operate with this and you're
not gonna get the rhetoric of us saying
you can use crypto for illicit [ __ ]
don't use it it's illegal and they're
most likely also putting like staff into
place in order to that's what it sounds
like too like all the people that you
were originally like a tax accountant
you can also do crypto you're a stock
broker you can also do crypto like
you're a bank you can open a crypto
account all the financial personnel and
just the whole infrastructure is now
okay to do crypto as well and that's why
i would say it is very bullish for
crypto because the more people adopt and
the more people have faith in it then
the more money is going to flow this way
also when you see governments using
their power to say oh you're my enemy i
don't like you because you just think
different from me
you can't you can't be a part of the
economy now or whatever and um it's not
a good case for you know obviously
russia because they're the enemy to us
right but imagine being a russian
citizen who has no [ __ ] power from
what putin does
it's like they're getting screwed at the
end of the day because american
companies and western companies are like
well [ __ ] putin we're gonna just you
know squeeze out your country so the
peasants the everyday people we have to
suffer for the actions of our leaders
right but then what crypto does is it
gives people an opportunity to go okay
well if crypto's being used and if
people are gonna take crypto and i can
go buy bread i can do these things then
you know what instead of trusting in the
ruble or the dollar maybe i'll trust in
crypto and then the q and then that's
the whole point i think of the whole uh
decentralized economy and this is like a
better case for that it's like see look
at what can happen here in this case
it's like okay we can use this as legal
tender we can use this as a way to like
purchase goods and and then the maybe
the citizens don't have to suffer that's
the part that sucks the most just the
everyday citizen that
isn't even like pro-war and they're just
living their life like a school teacher
or something that they you can't even
buy a uniqlo over there anymore you
can't buy apple products like nike none
of that but also yeah what sucks is it
is a tactic of war though it's like
espionage or whatever right where you
squeeze out the country's citizens so
there's uprising within and then if they
can't battle a war outside if people
within are just like trying to take down
the government then you have an
insurgency exactly is that a tactic of
war 100 sick dude we got the
confirmation
i got a real military guy to say that
yes which insurgency was the coolest
top five favorite
top five
the united states against britain when
we took over this country that's a good
answer that's a pretty cool [ __ ] good
answer god damn you [ __ ] hot guy yeah
this guy's so hot man it's crazy
somebody uh i i read on this tweet and
it was a really cool way of looking at
it that um things like bitcoin and stuff
like that is not so much the
value of money but the value of freedom
you know what i mean because money is
our we can tell in this time frame that
like money is a really volatile concept
you know i mean who controls it where
people's stance is on um like for for us
it's like technically i believe a barrel
of oil is actually cheaper than it was
like a year ago now technically and yet
they're still charging us more for it
because they can take advantage of that
you know what i'm saying like oil
tycoons and stuff so it's like the idea
of money is not so much what its value
is but like the freedom in which it can
like give somebody you know what i'm
saying so i think that's a cool bullish
concept for stuff like bitcoin so buy
more crypto then and here's the thing
this same bill an earlier version of it
was rejected
in september of 2021 by zielinski so
think about like the circumstances that
have to change 180 exactly right that's
like them arming their citizens
you know like it's a touchy subject but
then ukraine is uh it's you can't not
everyone can have you know guns and
stuff but then like they're handing them
out once it's like oh we're getting an
invasion yeah you have a gun
everyone gets a gun funny how that works
which is funny which is funny because um
you know one of the arguments for like
uh you know like the second amendment is
that like oh well what's the point why
do you need them ah there's no way
they're gonna ever evade america but one
of the reasons why japan was hesitant to
invade mainland america is because all
their citizens are armed so you're gonna
have to face not only their army but
militias a huge huge resource drain of
trying to take over every single town in
america so i was like damn that's pretty
interesting just gotta hit la new york
they don't have enough guns exactly
new york they're very anti-gun laws yeah
just hit san francisco
then you got the italian mafia that's
like hey i got it capisce no problem
you know
is that the guy from the home alone
cliff we have a lot of like police fund
that we don't have a lot of you there no
we don't not in l.a damn i think you
guys are wrong dude i think i think they
have a lot of resources right now yeah i
think they're locking a lot oh we have a
lot of we have a lot of asian hate
that's what we have oh we got an
abundance yeah what do we do with that
yeah that shit's crazy how it's all
politicized it's like god damn guys i
think i think there's uh
eight senators something like that in
america right now that are pushing a
bill to also uh
ask for
bitcoin to become legal tender with me i
saw that that would be so easy that'd be
a big change a lot of countries that are
stepping up to that exact same thing and
now we're starting to see that i think
in our own government right like people
just actually going to the house now
actually in the senate like actually
speaking up about the pro bitcoin pro
crypto kind of space and i think one of
the things that is being propelled the
most with the narrative is that we as
america need to be
winning the race for the innovation of
like financial technology and also just
like
i think there's also a fear to it it's
like i don't understand bitcoin but they
look like they're accumulating a lot and
we can't lose you know what i'm saying i
think that's a huge tactic to it how do
you think that's going to change the
market do you think that's going to help
i personally do also think that like
whether you accept it or not is a huge
thing right people didn't understand
[ __ ] bitcoin a couple years ago and
now it's all over the news yeah
understanding it is is even grandmas are
hearing about it on the news exactly you
know what i mean and it's like when you
think about like whether it be things
like ukraine and russia who are huge
miners of the currency and now they're
undergoing their things and it's like
potentially pushing people out when
china bans it all the miners go to
ukraine when ukraine has to shut down
because of russia it's like all these
miners they start going somewhere else
and then when you realize who has the
power
right who has the abundance to create
that opportunity for a minor to freely
do it untaxed or whatever and you can
harbor them in your country it's going
to lead to some sort of profitable thing
in the future and power thing on some
something as um that's not deflationary
but it's something as limited as like a
bitcoin you can only get so many
whoever's got the most chips at the end
of the day is going to have a lot of
power and it's like if we are still
arguing over here on like whether or not
it's it's used for illegal activity
that's all [ __ ] which is the worst
argument it's the it's the stupidest who
gives a [ __ ] all right who cares there's
so many companies now that are
legitimizing bitcoin right beside like
whether the government approves it or
not like what's a square that just
turned into block
like they are everything behind their
all the research projects is about how
they're going to get crypto oh yeah
market
shopify is about to accept yeah stable
coins instagram yesterday just announced
that they're going to make nfts
available via their entire uh wow so
it's going to be very social media and
like that's that you're that's talking
mass adoption now yeah integrating it in
ige that's all it takes right is one
giant company like that one 16 year old
tick tock girl to get an nft and you're
ended
[Music]
you